[Music]
all right thank you for all oh thank you
everyone for being here the last talk
[Music]
thank you to everyone in our studio for
putting on this great conference and for
inviting me to give this talk which will
be a bit of a change of pace
as I am much more of a historian than a
programmer so my name is Jesse Sadler
and I'm currently a lecturer at Loyola
Marymount University in Los Angeles and
today instead of going into some
technical details about tidy eval though
I have used tidy eval I am going to talk
about how the tidy versed helped me to
learn to code and then it helped me to
learn to create something to make a
package that solved a problem that I had
long had as a researcher in history ok
so what do I do
as historian my research is based around
studying sibling relationships and
inheritance in early modern Europe and
in the development of early modern
capitalism specifically I look at two
merchant families from Antwerp and their
social relationships the sibling
relationships and their inheritance so
what does that mean basically I spend a
lot of my time reading letters from the
16th century reading letters lawsuits
that were made between family members
especially Testaments and account books
and so I do this in archives in the
Netherlands and Belgium
there's even archive that work on this
in a castle in Belgium so that's fun
so I had long been interested in
learning to code or to to do something
with what we call and he managed digital
humanities and I had been interested in
this but I didn't know where to start
the power of coding from the outside was
very alluring so maybe some of you
remember this maybe some of you don't
but it's if you don't know what it is
it's it's exciting but you have no idea
what it could be
as I learned more about it I was
interested in the ability to build
something that was set up exactly for
what I wanted to do I had used
spreadsheets I was very much interested
in the separation of data entry because
I have to enter most of my own data from
the archives and separating that from
data analysis as Jenny Brian has talked
about a lot and so I was interested in
it but I didn't know what to do and a
lot of what people say when when you
know people come up and they say oh I
want to learn to code they say okay
we'll pick a project well I didn't know
what a project was okay I'll pick a
project what what's a project what
programming language am I going to need
what what do I even need I don't know
what I need so this really kind of kept
me for a long time and trying to take
what I knew from history from the
humanities in learning a whole new skill
I didn't really know what to do and so I
think that the tidy Tuesday whole
projects is really interest
in this regard because it demonstrates
okay here's something that you can do
and it's manageable and it's reasonable
and you can get it but I didn't know
that so I said okay I'm going to you
know after long period of not doing
anything I said okay I'm going to
actually put my foot down and learn this
whole digital thing so I said okay I
think I have a project that would be a
project I have in the archives 6,000
letters or over 6,000 letters that were
sent to merchants Daniel von der Molen
over a period of twenty two years from
1578 to 1600 and I said okay I could
probably map these and so I Haman HOD
and I thought about okay is there a GUI
application that I could just put some
data in and get something out and I said
no I'm going to learn how to do it by
myself I had some help from a friend and
I looked around and I said okay why not
this whole our thing so how then did I
learn how to program in our basically
well how did I learn how to program in
art and how did the tidy verse help me
that since that's my talk so the short
story is that I basically just read
garret Grauman's and has Lee Wickham's
our for data science i sat there and I
had it pinned to my browser and I would
read a chapter and I would take notes
and then I would read it again and so so
that's pretty much how I learned but
there's a lot of sophisticated arguments
about non-standard evaluation and
whether the syntax in tidier
is better than it isn't besar and all
those things and I'm not going to talk
about that because as a beginner it
didn't really matter to me which way was
better it just mattered that there was a
way and tidy verse I think really helped
me and that it was nice and bounded and
you could do things with it but it was
also limited yes deep liars a huge
package but you don't need to know at
least at the beginning about most of
deep liar so I really enjoyed the
bounded nature of it
you read in data with read are you do
something with it with deep liar and
then you visualize it with ggplot and
you're like yes I have something so that
ability it showed me that okay one I can
learn to do this so that's good but to
that it would be valuable for me to put
in the effort to learn how to do this so
what really scared me I think at the
beginning of learning to code and our
was what one of the things that makes
are great which is all the packages
there's so many different ways to do all
these different things but I was not
interested in that and so at the
beginning what I really was doing was I
took solace in library tidy verse and
just type that in and then know that
everything will be okay
and so here I really have to thank the
entire our community our studio
community its high diverse community for
helping me learn for all the great
resources that there are for keeping me
excited about learning more I started a
blog where I
went through sort of my learning process
at Jessie Sadler calm and the response
that I've gotten from that sort of has
been way larger than I would have ever
expected in the first project that I was
working on the SF package came out right
or was really getting going right as I
was doing that so it was great I really
had fun delving into SF and into GIS and
so far I have a map of letters up to
1591 it's not the code that's holding me
back it's going through and cataloging
all those letters which is a laborious
when you have to actually input your own
data the coding seems easier at least it
takes less time okay so what I want to
do for the rest of the talk is to
discuss a new project that I've been
working on a package that I have built
that deals specifically with a historic
issue and so we're really going down to
narrow use case but hopefully you'll
bear with me here
so the package that I have developed
I've called Deb keeper which is short
for double entry bookkeeping or double
entry bookkeeping
which I know sounds amazing already so
this is on github right now but the
package is basically there's more I want
to do with but it's basically ready and
it has a package down website with three
vignettes and descriptions of how to do
things okay so let me start before I get
into what that is let me discuss what
the historical issue that I was seeking
to solve this so I'm interested in the
history of accounting and that might not
sound that interesting or you may be an
accountant I don't know but
the reason I'm interested in a history
of accounting is because accounting
deals with social relationships it's not
the accounting part it's the social
relationships and why accounting is
particularly interesting for me in my
context is that in the early modern
period in most of the Low Countries
where I do my work inheritance was
perfectly partible meaning that all male
and female heirs receive the exact same
amount of inheritance and when you're
dealing with merchant families that
means accounting has to go into figuring
out how much the estate is worth and
then how much each individual person
gets and it has to be exactly right so
and here you can see a document where
it's doing that so merchant families
inheritance involves accounting now one
problem with that other than its
accounting is that the currency that
they use as you can see on the right is
essentially pounds shillings and pence
one pound if you can't remember before
pre decimalisation equals 20 shillings
one shilling is equal to twelve pence so
this creates a number of problems
because it's not decimal firstly erect
arithmetic calculations are cumbersome I
never thought I would be doing so much
arithmetic as a historian so I have
pages and pages of just doing
handwritten arithmetic it's not hard but
more importantly probably is how to deal
with tripartite non decimal values in a
database and so this has the same issues
if you're gonna try and think about it
in our or any computer computers are
decimal and so firstly you have three
separate units
to make up one value the units have non
decimal bases and to make things worse
the bases can be different so 20 and 12
is the most usual but there's also 20
and 16 and there's 16 and 60 and 12 and
all sorts of different things okay so
how did I get over this in the def
keeper package I created a class that is
that I call LSD which comes from the
latin names for pounds shillings and
pence Libre solidus and Denarius so
you're getting some latin in here so
what does it do basically it makes these
values a numeric vector of length 3 it
also has a basis attribute that keeps
track of what the basis for the
shillings in pounds and pence are and
then they are stored as lists so that
you can use them as a list column and
you can have multiple in one object so
this is basically what it looks like
here from a vector Deb as LSD Deb as in
double entry bookkeeping and then you
can also input these values as separate
columns in a spreadsheet or something as
CSV and then bring them together with a
function called Deb LST gather so the
coolest thing that I first started off
with and you might not think this is
cool but it was really cool to me
one might say magical was that I could
normalize the values so I could add up
pounds add up shillings out of pence and
then get what that value actually is and
when I got this to work and it's just
pretty much arithmetic behind the scenes
it really was nice or you can add these
together within a function
okay so let's do some harder arithmetic
so we can compare the Deb keeper method
with the method from the third edition
of the encyclopedia encyclopaedia
britannica from 1797 so this is how they
actually talked about doing arithmetic
so this is in the arithmetic article so
here you can see on the left a fairly
complex way in which they multiply
fifteen pounds three shillings and eight
pence by 32 they break it down into
eight multiplied by 8 and then multiply
by four and they're doing they're
carrying over the unit's
sort of behind the scenes division is
even harder
so I'm gonna concentrate on there's two
examples here but the example on the
right is and here we get two different
bases so this is a weight so it's
dividing three hundred forty-five
hundred weight one quarter and eight
pounds by 22 and if you try and figure
out what they're doing here it's really
confusing and they have little dots to
figure out where they are but it's not
helpful and so we have to change our
bases and so that's what you see there
at the bottom of the the third line
there is that the bases are so a quarter
weight is there's four in a hundred
weight and there's 28 pounds in a
quarter I didn't know this either before
I looked at this so okay so it's nice
that we get to not have to do all this
I like 5th grade math I mean it I never
knew that 5th grade math would be so
important but but what about larger
account books so this is a picture of
the person whose account book I've
worked on the most
the account book itself young Dilla
fired outta or the elder so his account
book if you look at the inside it looks
like this and it's about three hundred
pages and then there's two of them they
covered the period from his death on the
November eighth 1582 until the end of
December 15 ninety-four and even then
the siblings had intrest the heirs
hadn't received all their inheritance
ending in fact the heirs continued to
argue over the inheritance until
basically they died in the sixteen tens
and then their children also continued
to argue over it so what I want to do I
don't know how much time but I just want
to show some instead of showing the code
to do this show some visualization so
basically these this is things that I
couldn't do because I wouldn't want to
put all this data into a spreadsheet
because I didn't know how to do anything
with it and now I can so here you have
an overview of the beginning of the
estate when he passed away in the red
circles show the accounts that are in
debt to the estate and the blue in
credit to the estate and so the biggest
blue shows basically the amount that
young data's assets were greater than
his liabilities forty one thousand one
hundred twelve pounds ten shillings five
pence and remember the pent matter
because they had to be equally divided
here you just have a little line chart
showing how and when the nine heirs
receive their inheritance this is my
version of a financial chart but it goes
over
years you see that before his death he
owed his children money because he owed
his children money for their maternal
inheritance which makes things even
worse then there's a long gap because
there's nothing because of the problems
that they had and then at the end you
still see nothing that they didn't
become even so just one last thing just
to show what's possible this is a
network graph again showing the accounts
and how they're related to each other so
this has obviously gotten me a long way
from where I started but basically I was
able to get here because of the skills I
gained by looking into the tidy verse
and that's pretty much what I used in
the package so thank you for listening
and thank you for having such a great
conference
[Applause]
[Music]